the jurogan experience how many years
would have to go by before people were
doing commercial space flight
before you decided to just take a take a
shot see what's up
i think it could happen tomorrow if
somebody like
comes to you with a solid concept we're
going to put you in space
bring it right back down to earth i
don't think space is as big a deal right
now
i think that it's a big business uh and
the fact that uh all the richest people
in the world are in it
prove it you know that'd be like saying
oh my gosh you can't ship this package
that
it's going to be five thousand dollars
on fedex
the fact that the richest guys in the
world are in it means
it's very cheap and you can get the hell
out of here
is that what it means i think it means
there's a lot of like
benefit in being one of the people that
innovates in space travel
if you could come up with a thing where
you send people into space
and every time you do it you could
charge someone 100 grand
and you get like a million people a year
to give up 100 grand
and go flying into space that's a lot of
[ __ ] money it's only 100 million
dollars
a million people yeah that's right yeah
i mean i don't want to talk about your
past or anything no it's not a hundred
it's a hundred thousand yeah yeah
it's uh it's not a hundred million
that's uh
a 100 billion well that's when you start
moving commas and not
zeros well that's when you do math yes
so like if you're jeff bezos and you can
make a hundred
billion doing that
i mean you wouldn't make 100 billion
what if you make 50 every year
just putting people in space that seems
very valuable it's going to become a
commodity very quickly
yeah putting people in space it's like
space is just a high-flying airplane
right but if people are willing to spend
a lot of money doing it
and then if you can figure out a way to
escape
earth's gravity and land on the ma on
mars or land
on you know europa on one of the moons
yeah but what if you could figure out a
way to [ __ ]
fly around venus and come back home
what the [ __ ] is the point the point is
the experience
just like the point of going to everest
like is the point being at the highest
spot
like who gives a [ __ ] if you under the
highest spot nobody gives a [ __ ]
but the point is the experience the
experience of going there and and
knowing that it's a difficult thing to
do and
it gives you an unusual vision
an unusual perspective an experience
that
few people rarely see ad blocky
[ __ ]
got a disabled ad blocker son he gives
you an option [ __ ]
tickets to mars will eventually cost
less than 500
000 elon musk says well thank you elon
what a bargain
[Laughter]
only a half a million i could fly all
the way around the [ __ ] earth
and stop 72 times for 500 grand but if
they really do get to that point
and they probably will look if you go
back to
the invention of the first automobile in
like the 1800s
and then you look at what they can do
today with like uh
jamie has a tesla model x they go
shut the [ __ ] up bro they're great it
goes they go 0-60
so fast it doesn't seem right and it's a
suv
they're so fast did you driven one
ludicrous mode yeah i haven't yeah
have you driven one like that yeah
they're preposterous they're so fast
insane so you go from that old car that
was like
you know [ __ ] 20 horsepower to what
he's got it's insane
now go a thousand years from now you
there's no way you can guess and if you
look at what we can do right now if
commercial space flight is a real thing
and they're flying people into orbit
there is no doubt
in my mind that what whatever the amount
of time it is whether it's 50 years
or 100 years from now they're going to
absolutely have
space flight to mars and bring people
home they'll prob
probably come up with some new
propulsion system some
some [ __ ] wild crazy [ __ ] that we
haven't even thought of before
and it'll change everything it's not
gonna happen with this
giant go straight up it's gonna have to
be something that circumnavigates
and gains alien technology nah i don't
know about any technology but it's gonna
have to be something that
circumnavigates and gains speed as long
as you say circums navigates
i i think you know what you're talking
about
circum imagine being like at nasa what
you guys need to do
those [ __ ] circums navigates exactly
get it around it's not going to go
straight up boys never go straight up
the earth spins you got to go with the
spin of the earth never go straight
go forward it doesn't go straight it
looks like it's going straight
but it goes straight in relationship to
where you're standing
but not in relationship to the way the
earth's spinning and the way the
[ __ ] planets are aligned it's all
complicated another [ __ ] ad pop-up
jesus dude that just doesn't even work
anymore i thought you were supposed to
be really good at this
he's the best that's not the problem
problems pop-up ads
nasa is launching a 4g mobile network on
the moon
yeah well when i have 6g i'm not going
to settle for 4g on the moon you [ __ ]
that's like getting like one x in the
amazon who the [ __ ] getting it on the
moon
[ __ ] how many customers are on the
moon jeff bezos is going to be with that
girl that you don't even like
on the moon i just wasn't impressed
martini i mean
if i was worth you know hundreds of
billions of dollars i think i could do
better
i gotta pee too so we can either wrap
this up or i can pee and we keep going
well i don't care i'll be right back oh
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] dare me
we got your notes i'm just picking up my
uh
have you thought about what i said about
space travel yes
and i'm not disagreeing what i'm telling
you is
as a race we take over [ __ ]
we try we go and grab [ __ ] we take over
it we fight about it we we say this is
our land this is your land
right if we'd have been in the moon
would would be up there
the argument is that every single
technological achievement from 1969 is
easier cheaper and faster to reproduce
today
except going to the moon that's the
argument
i say wrong because i was born in 69 and
that was [ __ ]
cheap
the argument is that everything from
then you could do cheaper today
and easier like televisions yeah but
they can't
well they didn't work at it that's the
problem it's the only thing they didn't
work at
the only other things they didn't work
at is like
how much innovation have there been in
air flight
in like commercial air travel not much
propellers it's been 100 69 they were
already flying jets
when did they start flying jets yeah oh
i guess yeah well then the concrete they
stopped sort of i guess with the concord
and then like yeah or
that thing or a lot of rich people or
they're not telling us how far they've
made it in
space well the concord killed people
that they can't kill
like that was uh what was that getting
you to france in like
two hours or something something crazy
couldn't have gone faster they just
kept it there or no i don't know i think
the thing that happened to them was on
the runway
i think it lost a wheel or something on
the runway and killed a bunch of rich
people or ran
into a tire something like that low
passenger numbers and rising maintenance
costs
i mean it was kind of expensive wasn't
it wasn't it sure
sorry i mean
super sonic speeds you know i mean how
the [ __ ] does it not break
it wasn't that bad but wasn't that bad
the price i thought for some reason my
head i thought it was
like a ticket thousands and thousands of
dollars how much was a ticket since the
fair was about 500 bucks or just over a
thousand dollars with today
in what year when did they stop 90. 99.
that's kind of crazy was the conclusion
stopped in 2000.
that's kind of crazy if you think about
progression
like in 2000
you could fly at supersonic speeds
commercially you can't do that now
so that kind of throws a monkey wrench
into the idea that things always get
better
because they don't always when they cost
too much money they don't always get
better
i don't think it costs too much money
they were complaining about the uh
sound and the sonic boom
oh yeah that too right yeah yeah but i
think there was also the danger of it
it's like people a bunch of the last
flight i think a bunch of people died
that were very wealthy is that true
only thirteen oh yeah
that's a little more than 13. that's
[ __ ] serious yeah
and a lot of them were very wealthy i
think when you get hit with those
lawsuits like
so that's one of those things that from
2000 to 2020 did not get better
it actually stopped you know it's it's a
lot of money to get people on the
[ __ ] moon
it's just one of those things where i
think eventually they'll get to space
tourism
and it'll expand past the moon it'll go
to mars and it's going to happen
but it might happen a hundred years from
now you know it might happen 200 years
from now
we might be shocked at how long it takes
well then you're pleading my case right
there
why am i playing your case because we
haven't been there you might have did it
once
yeah you might have did it once in a
bunch of [ __ ] cowboys okay you went
to high school in the in the
uh or even uh elementary school in the
70s right
and you studied history have you ever
seen a picture of the flag on the moon
of course i have no through a telescope
oh me do you know they don't have
telescopes that could actually see
that that clearly yes they can really
yes do you know how you see this work
they don't work that way they don't like
them there's a there's a like a long
distance thing
and then there's a close distance thing
like you could use
magnifying things like binoculars and
telescopes that are like low
magnification and you can get like a
good image of something that's not too
far away
but then when they started getting too
far away yes the flag is still on the
moon but you can't
see it using a telescope the hubble is
not pointed
at the flag here goes the hubble space
telescope is only
2.4 meters in diameter much too small
resolving the larger lunar rover which
has a length of 3.1 meters
would still require a telescope 75
meters in diameter so we're the most
badass country in the [ __ ] world and
we put a man on the moon and he planted
a
[ __ ] flag mm-hmm and we ain't showing
that off
right but i mean because we're as a
country we're like burt reynolds
what are you gonna do we're gonna show
off
that's what we do but did you read what
that thing just said
i i get your like country wisdom where
you're looking at it and you're like if
we had this we would have that
but if you look at that thing it's
saying that the hubble only has
uh a thing that's 2.4 meters and you
need something much
larger was it 75 75 meters which is like
almost a football field size to be able
to
see what's on the moon like they didn't
have the hubble before right they didn't
have the ability to take these high
definition images of things that were
like way far away
now they do but to have something that
gets
really close to things you need
something that's even more potent
it's all for people not like you or me
we're arguing about [ __ ] that we don't
study that's why
i'm not even i don't even care about it
to tell you the truth
i'm just telling you you brought it up
on a podcast millions of people are
listening
i'm totally screwed now uh
whatever i said gas monkey bar and real
god that you're in a [ __ ] argument
with he's gonna
bring that to court [ __ ] that this guy's
crazy
[ __ ] he thinks neil armstrong is a liar
[Laughter]
so what's next sir aliens
i don't care about anything i think
they're paying attention
personally if you were an alien wouldn't
you be fascinated by hot rod culture
well um i met an old guy
a long time ago and he put it to me the
right way he goes
what if you're just
a experiment in a young kid's
school project what if all this that you
built is
basically an amp form that you have in
your head and you're just an amp form in
somebody else's head and somebody else
said it's kind of like the matrix
i don't know if that defends us or
defines us but it is kind of interesting
i mean you can't think that you're the
only thing out there or we're the only
thing out here
if we are an ant farm and we don't
know that we're an ant farm and we're
living and we understand
how the ant farm works
the real problem is if the owner of the
ant farm
shows up up until then we're just living
you know if this really is like some
complex ant farm for people
we're having fun well it's all good yeah
problem we got some weed we got some
drinks we're having fun we're making
money we're not making cars
talking [ __ ] everything's fine the real
problem
is if the ant farm owner shows up
that's the problem with these [ __ ]
ufos that keep showing up the ones that
you the
new york times puts on the front page of
their newspaper
is that a real newspaper yeah it's a
real paper it's they do it in new york
state it's a city called manhattan well
now i've been there
without it i just don't know about new
york times being a paper
well they're more often a paper than
they are not
sometimes they [ __ ] things up but
they're more often accurate than not
yeah they were more accurate in the past
than they are now
now they're i lodge ideologically driven
and they tend to be a bit woke
but they're still probably the best
newspaper on earth should say woke
yes woke you know woke
[Laughter]
there's rules you know the work
woke rules
you don't give a [ __ ] about those right
i do not me neither
um but do you think that aliens have
visited
i'm gonna give it a 50 50. i'm gonna
probably lean towards yes
is this anything you think about on a
regular basis
only when i'm jacking off
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience